here was one of the most influential and
talented entertainers the world has ever
seen but he was also one of the most
complex generous and a loyal friends
champion of the underdog a devoted
family man but he was also a womanizer
he was a volatile he was loud mouthed he
was a tough guy he lived a life on the
edge full of excitement danger and
passion so how did this skinny Italian
kid from New Jersey become an
international superstar and the world's
first true multi media artist well in
this episode of biographic we go behind
the veneer to get up close and personal
with the chairman of the board
[Music]
Francis Albert Sinatra was born on
December 12th 1915 Hoboken New Jersey he
was the only child of Italian immigrants
Martin and Dali Sinatra as such he was
pampered by his parents who lavished the
best of what they could afford on their
son still little Frankie grew up lonely
and alone
Martin Sinatra was a down-to-earth
easygoing and hard-working City fireman
his mother was just the opposite
driven involved in political issues and
proving herself the driving force of the
family she belongs to every organization
in Hoboken and had a reputation as an
extremely dominating character while
both of his parents worked young Frank
learned to look after himself if he
wasn't home alone he'd be out wandering
the neighborhood where he quickly
discovered how to become street smart he
grew up in a world of Prohibition
bootleggers and speakeasies school was
never a priority for the teenage Frank
he would often skip class to hang out in
pool halls boxing gyms and on street
corners he seemed develops a reputation
as a stubborn ornery kid who never
backed down often the subjects of racial
taunts he would never let an insult past
a friend recalled that once he and Frank
were walking down the street when
someone said hey you little wop - Frank
his friend told him to keep on walking
but an enraged Frank blurted out I'm
gonna walk all over his face the only
problem was that Frank didn't really
know how to fight and he subsequently
got beaten to a pulp when his friend
asked him whether it was worth it he
replied hell yeah he'll never call me a
what again however two days later the
same thing happened same guy same
results by the age of 16 Frank had
ditched school altogether he worked at a
series of odd jobs including as a dock
worker and a newspaper boy but he often
got bored and would quit a solid job
after just a few weeks when he walked
out on a job working in the
refrigeration units of cargo ships his
father had enough he referred to his son
as a quitter and told him if you want to
be a bum go somewhere else and be a
barman
Frank didn't have to be told twice he
packed up his few belongings in a
suitcase and took the train to New York
City by now he'd set his sights on
making it as a singer but no doors
opened for the skinny Italian kid he
couldn't find any employment at all let
alone a singing gig with nowhere to stay
and no money for food he had at home I
would Lee Dali mocked her son singing
ambitions referring to him as mr. big
shot before smacking him on the head but
behind the scenes
she began visiting clubs and asking
managers to give a boy a chance this
resulted in a short-term gig in a
Hoboken club but the job didn't last
Frank got in a fight with the proprietor
and was shown the door when he was 17
dolly and Marty lent frank $65 so that
he could buy a portable address system
and sheet music arrangements this boot
in may step ahead of other aspiring club
performers Frank then later began
collecting orchestrations he later
explained his strategy bands needed them
I had them if the local orchestra wanted
to use my arrangements and they always
did because I had a large and
up-to-the-minute collection they had to
take singer Sinatra too in this way
Frank managed to establish a foothold in
the local club scene his hero was Bing
Crosby and he tried to copy the Crosby
sound but when he noticed virtually
every other singer out there was doing
the same thing he made the decision to
establish his own unique sound
in the summer of 1934 the
eighteen-year-old Frank met 17-year old
Nancy Carol Barbato she came from a poor
family in Jersey City in New Jersey
Nancy was sitting on her front porch
doing her nails when Frank walked up to
her with a ukulele in his hands his
opening line was yo what about me I
could use a manicure too
the spark was lit and the romance
blossomed over the next four years they
lived one town apart and Frank would
frequently take the bus to visit and
date Nancy during these years
Frank was building his singing
experience most gigs would pay around $2
a night sometimes he performed at road
houses for nothing more than a sandwich
or a box of cigarettes Frank's first
break came on September the 8th in 1935
when he auditioned for a spot on the NBC
radio show major Bowes and his original
amateur hour this show was broadcast
live from the Capitol Theatre in New
York City
Frank teamed up with a group called the
three flashes and they became the
Hoboken four they performed the Bing
Crosby hit shine and won a spot on the
show which was sort of a 1930s
forerunner to American Idol listeners
phoned in to vote for their favorite
acts and the Hoboken four proved so
popular the major Bowes invited them to
return several times
however the radio show appearances
didn't lead to any lasting success
Frank returned to Hoboken and soon found
himself once again begging for jobs
anywhere he could find them in 1939
Frank and Nancy they were married not
long after that Frank was singing in a
club called the rustic cabin in the
audience was Harry James a big bands
leader who was auditioning for a lead
singer James was impressed with Frank's
way of working a lyric he invited
Sinatra to audition the next day
although there were a lot of others who
showed up for the job when Frank opened
his mouth the matter it was settled he
made his debut with the Harry James band
on June the 30th 1939
at the Hippodrome Theatre in Baltimore
the rest of that summer and into the
fall he toured with the band too
enthusiastic audiences by 1940 Sinatra's
popularity it was growing steadily then
he changed bands midstream jumping at
the chance to sign on with the more
famous Tommy Dorsey Orchestra the deal
though Frank struck Lee was hardly in
his favor he would give up a third of
his earnings for life plus 10% for
Tommy's agents but all that young Frank
who had recently become a father wanted
was to sing and be famous and besides he
would end up with more each week than he
was getting with the
old man's with this band frank travelled
across the country and he ended up in
Hollywood California in 1942 the bands
with Sinatra out front made a cameo in
the MGM movie ship ahoy with band behind
him Frank had built up his profile he
appeared on the radio in concert halls
on TV and in the movies by the end of
1942 he was one of the most well known
singers in the country and he had
replaced Bing Crosby has billboards top
band vocalist and cut his first record
with the band
by the end of 1942 Frank had made up his
mind to go it alone he was clearly the
star attraction of the Tommy Dorsey
bands so while they may have needed him
he was more than able to hold an
audience by himself when he told Dorsey
of his intentions the band's leader was
furious but Frank was determined and
finally Dorsey relentless he did insist
however that the contract for a third of
Sinatra's earnings would remain in place
Frank decided that he would worry about
that contract later for now he would get
out before Dorsey changed his mind
Sinatra made his solo debut on his 27th
birthday December the 12th 1942 in the
audience that night was Bob Whiteman
manager of the Paramount Theater he was
so impressed that he asked Benny Goodman
the King of Swing if he minded having
Frank on a bill with him at the
Paramount Goodman's response was who the
hell is Frank Sinatra well he would soon
find out Sinatra's appearances at the
Paramount made history it was the start
of the type of hysteria epitomized by
screaming and fainting girls who would
later greet Elvis and the Beatles when
Frank at the stage the theater erupted
with wild scenes that had never been
seen before in 1944 with his popularity
absolutely soaring Frank became a father
for a second time Frank Sinatra jr.
joined older sister Nancy at home while
their father's star kept ascending his
record sales tops the Billings and he
was the most requested voice on the
radio
with the end of World War two Sinatra's
Fame rose to yet another level he was
contracted by Hollywood to star in a
series of musicals each more popular
than the last yet in his personal life
things were starting to unravel he was
away from home so much that he hardly
saw his wife and children then in 1947
Frank met and fell in love with a
beautiful and glamorous actress David
Gardner the two began a very public
affair which lost Sinatra quite a lot of
popularity among the older demographic
at the same time the 31 year old
crooners voice was beginning to show
signs of strain and he was also being
attacked by mainstream media outlets for
his support of liberal causes it was
said that his fight against segregation
was communist inspired reporters also
began claiming that he dodged the draft
during the war leading the print assault
on Sinatra was reporter Lee Mortimer on
April the 8th 1947 the two men came
face-to-face at Sierra's nightclub in
Hollywood Frank went straight up to the
reporter and called him a fruit and then
proceeded to use him as a punching bag
Frank's bodyguards quickly broke it off
with Sinatra yelling next time I see you
I'll kill you
little degenerate Mortimer had Frank
arrested and charged with assault and
battery the charge resulted in Sinatra's
gun permits being revoked Mortimer later
sued for $250,000 and the case was
eventually settled for nine thousand
Sinatra never seemed to appreciate that
his choice of associates could impact
his career in 1947 not long after he
beat up on Mortimer
he went to Havana to meet with the
mobster boss Lucky Luciano this mob
connection was to stick with him for the
rest of his life despite the affair with
Ava Gardner Nancy Sinatra stuck by her
husband's side she gave birth to a third
child Christina on Father's Day in 1948
but the new addition did not bring Frank
back into the family fault his
fascination with Ava was greater than
ever
unlike Nancy if we could match him drink
for drinks cigarette for cigarette and
tantrum for tantrum they were an ideal
hard-living couple that hard-living they
it had a price in 1949 Frank's voice
gave out that combines with his public
reaction to his outrageous affair led to
plummeting record sales and sharp
numbers his radio show was dropped and
MGM cancelled his movie contract it
looked like the show was over for the
man who had been called the voice in
Nancy finally divorced from Frank in
short order Sinatra married Ava Gardner
he had formalized his love life but it
seemed there was nothing he could do to
resurrect his failing career the public
had simply become disenchanted with him
viewing him as a washed-up has-been
[Music]
it was during his period of hardship in
the early 1950s that Sinatra read a book
called From Here to Eternity by James
Jones when he learns that a movie
version was being plans he became
convinced that this could be his road
back to the top he set his sights on
securing the role of private Angelo
Maggio Frank secures an audition and
then proceeded to convince the movies
producers that he was Maggio he won the
part and he gave the performance of his
life
Sinatra won the Oscar for Best
Supporting Actor the following month he
signed a recording contract with Capitol
Records and his career was back on track
it appears that losing his fame and then
pouring it back had changed Sinatra as a
singer he now wore his heart on his
sleeve sharing in his performances his
inner struggles he became the first and
the best musical storyteller and it was
this ability that brought him the male
audience that he had never had before in
Sinatra they suave a tender tough-guy
but they wanted to be Sinatra's marriage
to Ava Gardner was tumultuous and it
ended in divorce in 1957 but his career
was going from strength to strength by
the late 1950s he was well and truly
back on top his album come fly with me
was a number one it was on the charts
for an impressive 71 weeks at the same
time his movie career was also hitting
new heights in the man with the Golden
Arm
he gave an extraordinary performance as
a heroin-addicted misfit for 1960s then
Storen emergence of a new kind of
popular music rock and roll
realizing that he couldn't ignore it
Sinatra tried to accommodate by bringing
out up-tempo albums in the early 60s
Sinatra also became a staunch supporter
of John F Kennedy
however Franco maintained his
association with key mob figures
Attorney General Robert Kennedy was
concerned that Sinatra brought these
underworld criminal figures too close to
the president he managed to sever the
relationship between JFK and Sinatra
Sinatra's last great movie role was 1962
s The Manchurian Candidate in which he
played a US Army officer Bennett Marco
after that he appeared to become bored
with movies and developed a reputation
as a troublemaker on the set his
attention had switched to Las Vegas the
new gambling capital of the nation there
he and his buddies became known as the
rat pack along with Dean Martin Sammy
Davis jr. Peter Lawford and Joey Bishop
Sinatra performed a mixture of stand-up
comedy and lounge music at the best
casinos in town then in December of 1963
so now
as fun-loving existence was jarring ly
interrupted when his 19 year old son
Frank jr. was kidnapped and held for two
hundred and forty thousand dollars
ransom Sinatra appealed to Robert
Kennedy who called in the FBI the ransom
was paid Frank jr. was released in the
kidnappers promptly caught with most of
the ransom being returns in 1964 while
filming von Ryan's expressed Sinatra
noticed a young actress named Mia Farrow
hanging around the set the star of a
popular nighttime soap opera Farrow at
just 19 seen became
Sinatra's constant companion via 30 year
age gap provided plenty for the gossip
columnist Stu get their teeth into
in 1965 the 50 year old singer won an
Emmy for the best television special of
the year the following year he recorded
one of his most popular albums of all
time
strangers in the night that's Enya 1966
Sinatra and Mia were married however
Mia's mellow hippie style was out of
step with Frank's hard-living ways and
the union only lasted for 16 months
following the divorce and finding
himself in danger of being yesterday's
news Sinatra began looking for a new
musical direction that would allow him
to compete with the hard-edged rock and
roll that was popular at the time he
found what he was looking for in the
song my way written by Paul Anka the
song which Frank recorded in 1969 has
become his anthem then in 1972 the shock
of his legion of fans Sinatra announced
his retirement he said that he was tired
of show business and wanted nothing more
than to relax read and think just as he
prepared to take his life easy life
threw another curveball his way he was
summoned to a congressional hearing team
to investigate his connections with the
Mafia lack of evidence forced the
congressional committee to drop its
investigation and the heat went off
Sinatra retirement though it never sat
easily with Frank and by 1973 he was
once again on the comeback trail this
time his focus would be on concert
performances he lapsed back into the
public consciousness with a television
special called old blue eyes is back
from there he went on to fill all of the
concert halls and big arenas across the
country he sang directly to his audience
dressed in a fitted tuxedo just as he
had always done in 1976 the sixth year
old Sinatra married for the fourth time
his bride was 45 year old Barbara Marx
she travelled with him as he played to
ever-growing crowds by the 1980s the
chairman of the board is a bonafide icon
he went on to help in Ronald Reagan's
campaign then
in 1988 the 73 year-old paired with some
of his former Rat Pack performers the
audience's absolutely loved it
in 1993 Frank made use of a
technological innovation to produce an
album entitled Frank Sinatra duets
he sang along with 13 top recording
artists though they were at different
places and times the record became a
number-one platinum best-seller and
outsold any of his previous recordings
the Sinatra lived out the last five
years of his life in relative quiet he
was plagued by ill health often going
into hospital with cardiac complaints
then the dementia set in he passed away
on May the 14th 1998 at a hospital in
Los Angeles with the official course of
death being hostak on May the 15th the
Empire State Building was turned blue in
New York and the casinos in Las Vegas
came to a halt in a tribute to the man
who very uniquely did it his way so I
really hope you enjoyed that episode of
biographic if you did there's a couple
of things you could do right now one is
hit that like button below also if you
want more stuff like this we put out
brand new videos every Monday and every
Thursday so hit that subscribe button
below and subscribe button doesn't do
what it used to on YouTube if you
actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday
won't put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching